let's see if we can name this guy right
here so in all of these problems I guess
you can call them we look for the
longest chain or the longest ring and
this one's pretty obvious here the ring
in the middle is clearly the longest I
guess you could call it carbon structure
here and it has 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 carbons
so let me highlight that it is 8 carbons
so we will be using the prefix prefix
acht and it is in a cycle so it'll be
cyclo octan dare no it's all single
bonds so it's cyclooctane so this right
here tells us that our core is cyclo
cyclo octane and now let's look at the
different subgroups or the different
branches off of the main ring so over
here we have a 1 2 3 4 carbon group it
is in a cycle or it's in a ring so this
is a cyclo this is cyclo 4 carbons are
beaut cyclo butane LLL because it's a
subgroup or it's off of the main off of
the main chain or the main ring so that
is our cyclo butane right there we also
have another cycle of butyl right here 4
carbons in a ring so that's another
cyclo beautiful up here we have 3
carbons in a cycle the prefix for 3
carbons is Probe so this is cyclo propyl
cyclo propyl cyclopropyl and then down
here let's start with the common names
because those tend to be a little bit
easier we have one two three four
carbons and actually we have it there
and there 1 2 3 4 these are the same
groups so we're going to be dealing with
the butte if we do common names and you
see it has this y shape we're kind of
connected to the base of the Y in either
case so we are dealing with isobutyl ISO
butyl isobutyl the Y shape tell
that we're dealing with ISO isobutyl
that's both of these right there now we
have to figure out how we're gonna
number where we're gonna number
ourselves on this ring and to do that
we'd look for we look for the we look
for the the group that is first
alphabetically and this is a little bit
of a confusing point sometimes if this
was a tert-butyl or a second butyl we
would consider the B but when it's
isobutyl it's all considered one word so
we'll consider the I so we need to
compare we to compare the I to the sea
to the sea to the sea
so the seas definitely went on on the
eye and if we look at all of these
cyclos cyclo butane so ver cyclopropyl
it comes first alphabetically so let's
make our starting point this
cyclobutadiene as well so we'll make it
that our starting point and we're going
to go in a clockwise direction so that
we could get to this one first so that
the next group is only going to be a two
otherwise the next group would have been
at 3 so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 so this is a 1
cyclo beautiful beauty
7 cyclopropyl this is a 2 isobutyl so
this is a 2 isobutyl and this is a 4
isobutyl so we want to write them all in
alphabetical order the cyclo butane so
we have a cyclo butane the beetle we
also have a 6 cyclobutadiene all die
cyclo let me capitalise that's where
we're starting die cyclo butane then so
we got those two guys out of the way and
then alphabetically cyclopropyl is next
so then we have a7 cyclopropyl let me do
that in that orange color of the
cyclopropyl cyclopropyl 7 cyclo propyl
propyl got that guy out of the way and
then at 2 & 4 we have an isobutyl so
then we have a 2 comma 4 and we have 2
of them so it is Dai Dai I so butyl Dai
I so butyl Dai isobutyl and then finally
cyclooctane so that's so we got these
the 2 2 and the 4 Dai isobutyl out of
the way and then we have our cyclooctane
so I'll just write the cyclooctane
cyclooctane and we're done this was the
common naming now if we want to do
systematic naming we would have to use
something else other than the isobutyl
and to do that let me do that over here
what you do is you use your connection
point as one and you just branch let me
do this in a color I haven't used for a
green so let's make that our core chain
so that is 1 2 3 carbons so it's propyl
propyl and then on the second carbon on
the number two carbon that we are
attached to on the number two carbon you
have a methyl group so this is one
methyl one methyl propyl that's what
each of these that's a 1 methyl propyl
and then that is a 1 methyl propyl
another way to think about an isobutyl
is the same is the same thing as a one
methyl propyl right this is the propyl
part and then this right here let me do
that that color that right there is the
methyl part oh sorry this isn't a one
methyl propyl let me be very careful
with my numbering this is the one carbon
two carbon three carbon the methyl comes
off of the second carbon so this is a
two methyl propyl one two three methyl
comes off of the second carbon this is a
two methyl propyl group and now when we
look at it alphabetically methyl propyl
still comes after cyclo beauty so it
definitely won't change the numbering of
things and so it still be last and it
also comes after cyclopropyl so if we
were to do the systematic naming it
would be one
die cyclo there's something very
strangely fun about this die cyclo
beauty and then you have your
cyclopropyl seven cyclo propyl seven
sites like a secret code and then you
have your now this is interesting you
have two of these guys right now you
don't say die when you have this kind of
more complex naming or the systematic
naming instead you use the word Biss so
we have this this so let me write it so
at the points we're at 2 & 4 2 comma 4
this this this thing I could just piss
to methyl to methyl propyl to methyl
propyl so this part right here is the
exact part is that part right there this
is a common name this is the systematic
naming and then we have our cyclooctane
cyclooctane and we're done